[Music]
dink-dink welcome back to the ginger I
know you welcome welcome know you
welcome back
Yomi welcome back reverse you know Tommy
no how do you do
no no thank you everyone for welcoming
me back to the podcast I'm so glad to
return no no no no me welcome back to
the podcast okay thank you you weren't
cool scrunchy you got there
thank you you know what else is cool
what buying clothes for up to 90 percent
off with right up segue on me
Wow my goodness you guys start shopping
at thredUP it is the world's largest
online thrift store with up to 90% off
estimated retail price go to thread up
thr edu p.com slash gin and Julian and
with that URL you get an extra 30% off
your order that's on top of the
discounts are already getting on the
website also if you have little minions
that walk around on all fours I'm
talking about dogs the farmer's dog is a
great service that will make them very
happy and you like making your dogs
happy right
it is farm-to-table healthy healthy
healthy dog food that they will enjoy
and they will ship it directly to your
house we'll go to the farmer's dog calm
slash annejulien get 50% of your first
two week trial of fresh healthy food for
your dog
thank you sponsors thank you sponsors I
thought you're talking about like really
give you a little minions to walk on all
fours they were talking about like kids
they can't walk the baby yeah don't
figure babies farmer's daughter I mean
it is human grade but don't do it maybe
do it Julianne okay well they don't walk
around on all fours they're not walking
they're crawling like a baby baby does
not navigate on their hands and feet at
the same time that's like a bear crawl
yes well you know you don't have the
upper-body strength yet well when
they're when they're just learning how
to stand that's how they do it they do
that they have their
their feet on the ground and their hands
and they're like a triangle and then
they push themselves up they like walk
their hands up something right it's it's
some sort of like in yoga where you go
from like a dog and you walk up to your
hands or your feet you know your feet
yeah but they like grab something and
you been rude we just started podcasting
get him in there hey Kareem you better
go no no we're not talking about you
we're talking about babies that use
their hands to climb up they don't okay
don't don't do it
no firm you do not get to be okay in
your bed go just ignore him
welcome to our podcast for 90% of is
telling Kermit totally in his bed he's
so nasty what else is new nothing anyway
um we missed you guys we missed the
broadcast it's been a few weeks but
we're back and Jenna had an idea to play
a little game today
keep it light have a little fun well I
really like the game guess that recipe
but we did it two times and I feel like
I won both times you absolutely did but
what I really like is the idea of just
finding out what's in something and what
is it that's what I liked about that
game and so I like many people I've been
looking up like little crafts to do and
some of them are better than others I
feel like but I'm also not judging
because especially if you have kids like
anything to buy you like a half an hour
of peace and quiet while your kids have
their hand runs on all fours it
literally does not matter how shitty the
craft is or the end product like it's
fun it serves a purpose but when I was
looking up crafts on Pinterest the like
necessary materials was making me laugh
really hard because out of context they
are ridiculous so let me hear him so
you're gonna read off the materials that
you need for any given craft you're
gonna tell me
what's that craft okay
are you excited Julie a medium
excitement would you say you're a
connoisseur of craft no i'm merconis
i'm a kind of snot I don't think that's
a word I do not do crafts very well and
all the crafts on Pinterest are not
something that I am good at just in
general sense arts and crafts
that's a weird combo because I feel like
I'm I can handle myself in the arts but
crafts know I'm the other way around
good at crafts bad at art can you move
the crying machine over to its bed you
have to just put him in the back he's a
lot of things but he is not a good boy
okay he's already out I don't know what
you want me to do I'm trying to play
guess that craft let's play here are the
ingredients for your first craft you're
gonna tell me what's that craft Julie is
that a new jingle the first thing that
you need is these are all very specific
okay
dollar store coffee filters dollar store
washable markers dollar store chenille
stems what is that
dollar store pony beads dollar store
zippered bags gallon size dollar store
or a spray bottle filled with water does
not have to be from the dollar store
that's a for some reason everything else
has to be from the dollar store that's
it can you read it again fast and
without saying dollar store every time
it's kind of confusing copy filters
washable markers chenille stems pony
beats zippered bags and a spray bottle
filled with water um what's that thing
where you go it's maraca all right what
you're making you're making a maraca
rocker what what in those ingredients is
making the maraca sound the beads mmm
interesting
in the gallon size bag when you melt it
turns hard and it's one becomes the
shape of a drumstick or maracas
interesting and inside you have the
Chanel stems that is what gives it the
coating who knows them yeah hmm and then
the markers are to decorate the maraca
do you know what I'm talking about it
makes it sound I know what a monkey like
that is that a maraca would you like to
know what we're making yeah what kind of
maracas are we making okay give me a
hint
okay is it a maraca it's not a maraca
the pony beads are not used to make a
sound and the coffee filter is the
biggest part of this craft hmm coffee
making coffee
this is coffee no okay
coffee filter biggest part of the craft
yeah it's like the main part how about
like a decorative artificial flower
that's really close really yes because
the coffee filters like the petals um
[Music]
artificial do you want me to just tell
you grass Julian I'm gonna tell you you
did not guess that crap what is it this
craft is a coffee filter butterfly you
draw on it and you spray it with water
and it makes a really cool watercolor
effects and the it's pipe cleaners is
what chenille stems are you put a little
piece of pipe cleaners and although
that's not what it said chenille stem
tough [ __ ]
Wow that is tough [ __ ] they're really
pretty but I got one okay two
ingredients Oh God
rubber bands tinfoil you're making a
tinfoil ball don't just blink at me
seven times in a row I'm not gonna
respond unless it's correct oh okay
you're not gonna in foil balls
once a tinfoil ball yeah it's not a
tinfoil ball you're guessing it right
but that's not what it's called you you
like other things hey you crumpled up
all the tinfoil and then cover it with
rubber bands and it's like a bouncy ball
the name of it is called what's on the
outside of it the rubber bands and then
what is it a bouncy ball no no bouncy
this rubber band ball it's called the
rubber band ball really just really
Julian put your dukes up I'm gonna this
is the hill I'm dying on okay yes it was
a rubber band ball you crunch up is he
crying why don't you just let me hold
you just let me hold him well behaved
dog you crunch up the tinfoil into a
small ball and then you just wrap it
with rubber bands
is that a craft yeah it's a craft it's a
cross that you can throw are you sure
that that's a craft yeah I looked up
crafts on Pinterest and that came up
therefore it's a craft okay blame the
perch the person at Pinterest who works
at the SEO department okay Julian would
you like to another
I wouldn't would you like to guess this
craft hit me all right you need a jar
water leave what our jar Julian look at
the door Julian jar jar water okay fine
got it
fine glitter you have to find glitter no
yeah bye fine oh okay thanks a ton of
cotton balls like a ton what's that
craft so why would the glitter need to
be fine there's my question why can't it
just be glitter there's different sizes
of glitter like real chunky type or mine
chunky glitter yeah chunky glitter okay
what's that craft well I
what are you making I think you're
making I think you're making unedible
sparkly marshmallows because you dip the
cotton balls into the fine glitter
mm-hmm is there garlic did you say no
there's no garlic Oh what was the other
thing you said the first one oh jar oh
okay so it's gonna be one of those
things at a nail salon with the jar and
the cotton balls in it except it's gonna
be like shiny cotton balls for your nail
salon so that when you clean your nails
you're cleaning the nail polish off but
you're getting glitter on it I don't
remember saying nail polish remover was
a how's it gonna clean your nails maybe
it's maybe you know there's nothing in
cotton balls that will take off nail
polish how do they how does it get off
mail polish you're moving well so maybe
you go to the salon wanting and glitter
up you don't need to take anything off
you come clean you're like hey I'm I'm
ready to go it's like you shower first
and then they rub your nails with these
cotton balls and then you have glitter
nails I'd pay for that okay what is it
it is a galaxy jar that literally
doesn't even make sense what even is
that I don't know but it's you take a
[ __ ] on the cotton balls this woman
says like literally three bags of cotton
balls and you just jam it with water and
glitter and paint and then you close the
jar and you just look at it and just
look at it I guess can you get and you
open it up and get get it everywhere no
I don't think so I think the point is to
just like look at it does it move like a
lava lamp or just [ __ ] sit there I
think if you shake it I hate that craft
that's like look you know what like
we're talking about crafts you do things
like oh it's a decorative butterfly or
it's a necklace with beads like you can
wear it it's functional that to me is
just it's like the deadbeat equivalent
of a craft it doesn't do anything it
just takes up space I feel like some
crabs are superior to other
and this is an inferior craft well I
mean depends what you want it seems like
the kind of craft that some adult made
you do as a kid and then it just sits in
your room and then like a year later you
open it up and there's just like water
and shitty cotton balls and it grew mold
they literally just poured water and
glitter on cotton balls and then use the
word galaxy and put it on Pinterest I
did I disapprove Gillian's mad at my
craft no not you just that that's the
worst thing ever but I love you
okay ready for mine that was dese what's
what's your good this one's good okay
I don't think you've ever seen a craft
like this watercolor paper fresh flowers
not those old crusty kinds okay hammer
wax paper and a picture frame oh you
make him like pressed flowers what you
know what this is yeah I've never seen
anyone take a hammer to flowers and I
thought that was so fun just hammer the
flowers and then you put it in the
picture for him that's the thing you
knew but that's pretty oh yeah okay yeah
you got that so quick I'm like surprised
pressed flowers I didn't know that was a
popular thing wait can I do it another
one cuz that was quick okay
okay ready
this is holiday-themed even though it's
not the holidays but might as well be a
whisk and chocolate kisses Julianne
that's not a craft guess what it is
you're just making your melting the
chocolate nope a whisk and chocolate
kiss and plastic wrap
hey sure this is a craft that's like a
food well it's a craft that you can gift
but it's not a food and I'll give you a
hint we whisk you a Merry Christmas
that's a hint but you're making a craft
out of food there's food involved in the
crafts but you don't eat it so basically
you take the whisk and you just wide
that open it up why would you do that to
a wizard you drop a bunch of chocolate
kisses and you let it close and then you
give to someone so it's a whisk full of
chocolate kisses and you wrap it in
plastic you say we whisk you and Merry
Christmas what that's not a crap it is
it's a craft that you gift it's a gift
that's not a crab I whisk you a Merry
Christmas okay you know I don't want to
whisk that someone's sprit you pull it
all out and you just maybe don't maybe
imagine like bringing that home and just
the pain of opening up the whisk and
jumping all these kisses L or you just
left a trail of chocolate kisses because
they're falling out along the way yeah
they probably will well that's why the
plastic wrap is there maybe I don't know
I didn't get that far I don't think
that's a craft
well I search craft and that came up
you tell me what's wrong okay hey yeah
I'm ready got simple ingredients
washable paint an ice cube tray and
water colored ice cubes I don't know she
was like we were hot so we just made her
paint cold oh my god I thought it was
gonna be like food coloring and then ice
cubes cuz that would have been like
edible but you can't eat that can you
eat that no Julian you're eating paint
so alright I mean with another one okay
paper towel roll empty make it empty
okay
aluminum foil rice clear tape a wooden
spoon a broom handle colored paper
optional funnel I made am I ready yeah
kaleidoscope that's not a bad guess what
the hell is a broom handle for I don't
know but who just has a broom handle so
you have the tube and you have the tin
foil and you have colored tape and then
all the sudden you have a broom handle
is it like a telescope Wow where did you
come from
no um I don't know kind of a hint maybe
it's also sort of like a musical
instrument is it the thing that you go
maracas now would be an okay time and
against Morocco what about the
cylindrical shaped maracas what's that
called a rain stick yeah no a rain stick
it's a rain stick that actually sounds
like green that's cool I like that it
makes noise
hmm that's cool I live with that you
like crafts that make noise mm-hmm does
your whisk full of kisses make noise
depends on how you use it but yes it
makes a lot of noise
what have you left all the kisses in and
started cooking something with it
it wouldn't be edible because the kisses
are wrapped in inedible what is it
tinfoil that they're wrapped in and then
there's plastic wrap - so you'd be
eating melted plastic might be good
though hit me with another one punch me
with another one okay I'm gonna punch
you with another one hunts me - paper
plates I was gonna go okay - paper
plates a clear plastic cup okay green
construction paper that's it markers
pencil scissors and a hot glue gun green
why green um cat a hint a green you're
making Kevin what's a shape it makes
when you put two paper plates together
an eight-oh like this the same shape as
one paper airplane you're better
together what have you stacked them the
other way trying to visualize this what
is so two paper plates uh-huh if one's
like this and the other is like that no
no no no yeah
okay so then there's a little bit of a
gap in the middle yeah frisbee hey you
want spring clothes disc yes really yes
what does that mean what's a disc think
of a disc put a put a disc
oh yeah the Olympics for the Olympics
okay think of that shape okay now put a
clear plastic cup on top of it what does
that look like a frisbee with a cup on
it yeah right yeah I don't know what
that makes an alien ship let's go let's
[ __ ] go okay you put the little you
cut out a little green alien you put
them inside the plastic cup and you look
like a little UFO I got it that's a cute
craft I like that one that that one I
would have loved to as a kid any I would
have loved to do as an adult it's really
cute unfortunately I'm either I don't
know what I am okay sorry
I'll read one now okay good I can't
believe you got dude those are tear wait
show me that picture I'm furious I hate
that rescue me I hate that like why
can't you just give someone a whisk with
a bow on it why you gotta fill it with
[ __ ] because it's a gift and it's the
giving season when Christmas happens not
now wait don't give anything giving
season hits when the gift hits all right
this one has cookies Julianne
these aren't crafts you're just you
looked up food no this website has
cookies I'm just warning you that there
are cookies on this webs
it's just Jerry be considerate here okay
so
this one's called no we don't tell me
what okay here we go
all right so you need oh god why does it
take me to this like list cuz that's how
Pinterest is like someone can just post
a recipe they have to write like their
entire last six months well not only
that but I like click the Pinterest pin
in post and it like brought me to a list
post then is one of the Pinterest one of
the posts is about this one is just like
all the all of them are getting clicks
from me right now like I'm sure this is
giving them all traffic which is great
but I also hate everything okay here we
go I found it I clicked it and it
brought me to a a JPEG all right this is
from crafty morning calm okay
you will need tell us what we need I'm
just gonna eyeball this you need silver
paint okay
shell pasta and bowtie pasta fine a
toilet paper roll uh-huh glue hot glue
yeah and some green paint too if you
want okay
gold balls little gold balls that's what
I'm seeing little gold balls maybe like
beads or something little gold beads are
you making like you're definitely
painting the pasta silver and then
putting it on the toilet paper roll
you're onto this yeah so what the [ __ ]
are you so hint mostly shell pasta just
one bowtie hmm
oh that's cute it's not cute it's not no
it's okay what's silver that has shells
oh oh is he like a like a turtle no oh
[ __ ] no it's not a turtle is he like a
like a little mermaid there is no he
also imagine that it could be silver or
green it's just kind of whatever you
want so the silver doesn't really hold
much importance in this recipe
[Music]
recipe craft I don't know I need a hint
okay Christmas
why are all of your crafts Christmas
because tis the season it's not the
season it's June tis the season I don't
know
it is Julian [ __ ] off with that I hate
it and I hate it a shell pasta Christmas
tree that is disgusting you pay
perfectly good edible pasta silver so
you can't eat it then you glue it onto a
used toilet paper roll no and then you
get this no what no oh that's cursed oh
it's so cursed and that there's cookies
so I'm gonna get ads for this now no
that's cursed I feel like there's way
better far more superior things to make
little Christmas trees out of than pasta
and paint and toilet paper rolls like
like what you go over to someone's house
and there's just like pasta trees all
over the place he walk into their house
was you're just accosted by pasta and
paint and it just smells of paint in the
house and hold on what accosted by pasta
been named called man I say Kosta that
pasta nice you walk in there's there's
painted pasta everywhere painted pasta
that's also a good man in you look in
the corner of the room there's a couple
little dogs eating what are they eating
pasta treats no they're eating farmers
dogs
farmers dog okay if you want your dog to
enjoy their food and eat a healthier
diet do with the farmers dog and not eat
pasta trees
Tony pasta trees eat farmers dog what do
you think the farmer's dog eats Julian
farmers dark I think that's probably how
they got their name anyway they provide
human grade and people tested recipes
developed by board-certified vet
nutritionists and we can be the proof
here okay every time it's breakfast or
dinner they
sprint at light speed to the feeding
area and who breaks the sound barrier he
breaks the sound barrier this is a shock
wave yeah it happens and they just they
look they can't get enough of it it's
really really convenient if you want to
sign up for farmers dog you go to the
farmers comm slash Jetta Julian you get
50% of your first two week trial of
fresh healthy food and the way you do it
is you fill out a little questionnaire
about your dog what type of dog they are
what their eating habits are okay do
they do that and then in a box a
convenient box that shipped to your your
front door is prepackaged meals for them
and it's so easy to feed them your dogs
will love it you will love it our dogs
love it so check it out go to the
farmer's dog calm /gen and Julianne get
50% off your first two weeks when you
sign up using that your wealth also
speaking of URL go to thread up coms
allows Jenna julie to get an extra okay
an extra 30% off up to 90% off
discounted secondhand clothing thredUP
is a really awesome way to be shopping
especially right now you can get crazy
good discounts on usually expensive
clothing because this is the world's
largest online thrift store and you can
filter by your size or the stuff based
on brands but it's nice to be able to
filter by size because then you're like
looking for things that will you know
will fit you and you don't have to like
find something that you like and realize
that they don't have your size you can
filter by size which i think is a really
cool feature
so beefed up your closet I don't know I
said beef buff up your closet without
ever leaving the house go to thread up a
thr edu P comm slash annejulien and
start saving now the end can I do
another one Shh yours are soul cursed
this is my last one though okay go ahead
okay I'm [ __ ] scared what you found
this is from Kim Speier DIY that's cute
and if you read it fast it's Kim's
Peretti okay just wanted okay so the
things you'll need for this recipe craft
craft there is eight billion pictures
oh my god okay you will need I love
Pinterest and I also [ __ ] hate it I
don't know okay you will need don't look
babe now looking guess what it is
okay dark yes okay okay you need icing
this is not a craft Julian what don't
you understand about lookup after all of
yours I've had food in them every single
one except for 800 powdered sugar Julian
this isn't a craft a ball ice cream ice
cream scooper scooper babe ice cream
cone Julian and the last thing you're
gonna need is sprinkles it might be I'm
not making ice cream why did you show me
that picture then because it looks like
ice cream that's the craft it's edible
ice cream cosplayed play-doh
I'm gonna rage quit you can't play with
it wait so why do you have frosting and
sprinkles if that's what makes it edible
you're making play-doh and then eating
it correct you're playing with it with
your filthy [ __ ] hands and then
you're eating it so you're making
playdough you're putting it in a real
ice cream cone you're using real
frosting in real sprinkles yes but
you're not actually using play-doh
you're using the ingredients that I
listed I'm furious
don't be furious what is that it's just
it's horrible it's you're using
icing powdered sugar and a real ice
cream cone to make fake ice cream
so you're basically making shitty ice
cream that you can play with with your
hands powdered sugar isn't gonna make
play-doh if you mix powdered sugar with
ice with icing it will and I don't think
you've actually tried that so to be fair
I don't know it's not it's not a craft
that's a food but it's it's a it's like
a sweet thing that looks like an ice
cream cone but it's just frosting or
whatever that's cute but that's not a
craft well they crafted it Julian I
tried I thought it was a good one it was
a bad one picture is cursed do you have
any more yeah are you ready yeah okay
this one's complicated are you ready for
your complicated yeah I'm ready for a
complicated one pipe cleaners pom-poms
googly eyes glue gun that's it googly
eyes pom pom pom pom it's a pom pom pom
pom is that the things that cheerleaders
use no well yeah you're not wrong but I
think they're referring to like the
small little puffy balls like this oh so
pipe cleaner glue eyes you're making
eyeballs googly eye balls what happens
if you take a pipe cleaner you put a pom
pom on it and you put googly eyes on the
palm stick-figure sick face do you want
to know what they did with them they're
so cute they wrap them around their
fingers and their finger puppets oh
that's cool isn't that cute
that's really cool that one's really
cute that one's a ten out of ten
finger puppets I can get down with that
craft that that serves a purpose if I
was a little kid I would really like
that all right Julian here's your next
one okay a tablespoon of self-rising
flour food coloring this is a recipe
salt and a little bit of water gruel yes
is it well can you make out of that a
gruel omelet Gromit self-rising flour I
don't know are you just making paste or
something you are making homemade puffy
paint puffy paint but like it doesn't
look that good so much look at oh so
it's just like rises after you paint
yeah but I don't like does that last
like how does that work that's that is
so gross I hate that I don't understand
what happens to it I I hate it did you
see the pictures of it here look at the
pictures of it it literally looks like
[ __ ] it looks like you would need to
clean it up as soon as you're finished
like you wanted to just wipe it off yes
I don't know if it like dries or like
how it works but yeah that's homemade
puppy paint that's the worst thing ever
that's it that's a way to make painting
something fun nasty and weird it it like
it visually looks very uncomfortable
I hate it I'm uncomfortable alright
Julian okay what do you got half a cup
of warm water a tablespoon of borax one
to two tablespoons of clear Elmer's glue
that's borax what is borax can't look it
up a little bit borax is okay Chet do
you know it's a chat do you know if
you're watching what borax is borax
powder is it powder oxy clean borax
detergent booster oh so it's detergent
booster mixed with what else glue and
water and water fake snow
it's not a bad guess
fake bird poop Julian is it wrong
paper mache that's not how to make paper
mache Oh
borax mache are you ready yeah it's a
bouncy ball really yeah yeah that's cool
hi don't you use borax to like make a
like gak and slime stuff to like glue
it's kind of similar to that but for
some reason it dries cuz I didn't read
the rest of the craft that's kind of
cool that it hardens it and you can make
a bouncy ball out of it that's pretty
cool all right Julian just this crack
river rocks they got to be from a river
or else we don't wanna acrylic paint in
red and pink or pink okay
paint pens in two shades of green medium
and light white and black paintbrushes
paint palette modge podge what's mine
scotch I think it's like the clear
coating that you paint over something to
seal it so you're making your painting
the rocks and you're gonna coat them and
then they're gonna you're gonna play
Mancala with them that sounds fun is
that right or is it maybe you say I love
you on the rocks in pink and it's a
valentine's rock yeah it's cute
what else I don't know do rocks painted
like watermelons so dude
that's actually kind of cute I would
want to eat it though that's the problem
I just it's funny to me that you would
see a picture of that and you wouldn't
be like oh that's fun like someone had
to write a whole entire Pinterest post
as to how to paint a rock yeah why do
they why why why why can't why can't we
keep it simple I don't know all right
this one this one gives me hives yeah
yeah yeah I like it already
okay you need a like jar or a vessel
glass vessel canola oil vinegar food
coloring
baking powder I hate it homemade
homemade lava lamp how in the [ __ ] did
you guess that kidding me I got it yes
it's so uncomfortable like there it's
not a lava lamp it's just like bubbling
because there's no heat right you're not
gonna apply heat yeah I dangerous and
here's the best part she just takes up
flashlights and shines it from under the
bottom of it and the lights
that's so shitty it's called a lava lamp
there's no table like there's nothing
it's not contained you just dump nasty
[ __ ] into a bottle and Palash light
under it I can't I heard oil and I was
like they're definitely making a lava
lamp I don't know why I don't know why
my brain thought that remember how cool
those were when you were a kid though
yeah they were they were really cool
like you had one and you could just sit
there and [ __ ] look at it that's
crazy you just look at a lamp I just
like I'm not sure I would ever be like
mmm lava lamps are cool let me see if I
can make one no that's one of those
things that falls under the category of
yeah you should probably just buy it
because that is not a DIY lava lamp
mm-hmm no it's not it's oil in a cup
shitty smelly mess yeah it kind of
probably does smell huh it's like that's
the roll-up window equivalent of a craft
I hate it boo boo boo okay
well one more all right you need like a
face a flat glass container milk food
coloring I'm watching a video
whoo food coloring red food coloring
yellow food coloring you're making a
rainbow lots of different colors Oh God
you making a physical rainbow soap okay
I quit
rainbow soap YUM milk and soap be like
YUM here you go
you just dump all that into a container
and then you take a q-tip covered in
soap and all the milk moves away from it
and what's the point of it you just look
at it and then when you're done you
throw it out no one you done you you
chug it okay I want a bomb
I want a bomb and you know what's [ __ ]
is when all the colors mix together it
just looks like vomit it doesn't even
look cool
yeah milk they couldn't have done starch
and water milk is what they decided milk
it's probably a nice craft like if
somebody set it up and they did it for
you you'd be like oh that's fun but when
you hear the ingredients I'm like what
am I going to the store for milk and
soap no no you're not you're going to
the store for some dumb [ __ ] milk soap
should stay at home and not go to the
store look and so no cut cut that idea
out of your life can we report Pinterest
posts can't how do you block a Pinterest
post yeah well some of these were good
that one was awful some of them were bad
didn't you like the lava lamp you want
to make that later yeah let's make it as
long as we have to sit there and
manually light it ourselves so we didn't
even enjoy it yeah you do okay and then
also will we be using perfectly good oil
that we could in other words cook with
yeah okay and then when you're done it's
it probably stops moving around but
we're gonna keep it right okay and then
when we decided to throw it out coming
pour it down the drain so it actually
[ __ ] up in clogs our drains plumber for
sure that's my favorite part of that one
okay okay yeah yeah
and then there's glitter too so it'll
get everywhere hopefully you know he's
add glitter
yeah I'm down let's do it now this is
fine this is a good idea I like how all
of your crafts were just food well I'm
hungry I don't know but I do think that
there is a nice little intersection of
crafts and recipes that needs to be
appreciated mm-hmm you know crafts
recipes that's my wheelhouse right there
Kress apiece Mon Cala but the pieces are
edible okay you're done that sounds fun
let's play them on collar with jelly
beans oh that's dirty though dirty
well our hands are touching all the
things and then though you're the one
that suggested it it's not sanitary I'm
down when I was a kid we used to play
poker with juju coins
mmm you know the barely grade gummies
can taste like swedish fish yeah and we
would play poker with them nice it was a
good time oh yeah we all touched them
many times before anyone ate them
disgusting I don't know it's kind of
cool I used to put skills in my pocket
like just the skittles not at the pack
yeah what happened to them well
sometimes they would come up with a
little lint on them sometimes I would
wash my shorts and then I would have
rainbow pockets and I also nope that's
that's all I used to put bugs in my
pocket
that's cool that's I feel like that's
even more more normal than skittles yeah
okay
good talk good talk well good podcast
thank you guys for hanging out with us
for another episode we'll be back next
week and quickly I wanted to say
something recently it was brought to our
attention by one of you and I wanted to
thank you
your name is Ellie you reached out in
regards to one of our previous sponsors
with the podcast notifying us that there
was a sweepstakes going on that we were
promoting for the part of the podcast
sponsor that we were told and assigned
to promote with that copy that they gave
us that wasn't actually running for a
good amount of the time that we were
promoting it we are currently with our
team working on a solution to where we
will create our own sweepstakes to make
that up to all of you so just really
quickly want to say thanks to Ellie for
making us aware of this and we wanted to
apologize to you guys for misleading you
although it wasn't our fault we did take
part in it and moving forward we're just
gonna we're gonna create our own so
we'll make it all right for you I
thought we didn't want to just let you
guys know we know about it and thank the
person who brought it to our attention
anyway we'll be back next week I hope
you guys have a good week stay safe
black lives matter
stay vocal have conversations and we'll
be streaming live on Twitch as well
including my new cooking show which is
live on twitch this Friday a great time
mmm I still have very crispy streets to
eat we still have some alright karma
thing bye guys
[Music]
you
[Music]